[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a canadian comedy film
called no men beyond this point
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
at the beginning of the movie we are
introduced to a 37 year old man named
andrew myers he happens to be the
youngest man on earth
father ermano bassey is also one of the
few men alive he tells us how the
extinction of the male species first
started the father has been a priest
ever since he was a teenager and was
familiar with the concept of a virgin
birth when it all started before the
crisis every year about three or four
women claimed to have gotten pregnant
without sexual intercourse it was
regarded as a miracle and one timely
event by the church even though
scientists didn't agree with it but
everything changed in 1953 when in a
single year 67 women came forward
claiming that they got pregnant even
though they were virgins at the time it
first began many people followed
christianity which validated virgin
births as miracles science couldn't
prove if the claims were untrue because
there were no dna testing methods then
the people only had access to blood
tests that proved if someone is not the
father and there was no way to confirm
if the child had a father at all when it
all first started people believed that
by nature a baby can only be born when a
sperm fertilizes the egg so even though
many women were coming out with their
stories the only logical conclusion
seemed to be that they were all lying
one of the first women who experienced
fatherless pregnancy was helen duvall
she is currently over 60 years old and
is finally sharing her story in 1953
helen was a young married woman when she
got pregnant back then there were no
pregnancy tests so she was in utter
shock when the doctor announced her
pregnancy because she and her husband
hadn't had sex in over a year the couple
went for a second appointment to see if
the results were incorrect but they came
out positive the second time as well
helen's husband left her because he
thought she cheated she doesn't blame
him as anyone logical would have thought
the same there was no other explanation
for the situation she was in over the
years she told her story to a lot of
people but the harder she tried to
convince people she was telling the
truth the crazier she sounded eventually
she too started to believe that she was
crazy it wasn't until 1988 when a dna
test was developed that people finally
believed her truth a tv interview from
1945 shows us a man talking about
fatherless birth claims he says that the
thousands of women from around the world
coming forth with such claims are all
lying according to him women are prone
to hysteria by nature which means that
they are copying each other to create
this trend of false births to hide their
mischievousness even when the trend
began to grow to a larger scale the
world leaders who were all men at the
time ignored it mostly because they
couldn't handle the fact that they
weren't needed for procreation anymore
as time went by the more women came
forth with fatherless pregnancies the
more men disregarded their claims
because of this women began to harbor
anger towards men that was soon going to
change the course of human history
then sister isabella came along she was
a nun who was living in a convent in
northern spain where men were strictly
forbidden from entering but to
isabella's dismay she got pregnant one
day the church which was run by men
wanted nothing to do with sister
isabella and disregarded her completely
so she and the nuns came together and
protested this triggered the women all
around the world who had been
suppressing their anger until then in
1954 women united rally came to the
streets of washington dc the men in
power tried to calm them by saying that
the scientists are still trying to
understand how this phenomenon can be
possible but the protests didn't stop
there women had had just about enough of
being called liars the working women
stopped going to their jobs while
housewives stopped looking after their
families they joined hands and rallied
in the streets a clip from 1955 shows us
that helen duvall's husband had come
looking for her wanting to take her back
as his wife however helen had come to a
realization by then she didn't need him
for anything in her life he can make his
own damn dinner from now on soon women
all over the world realized that the
men's primary job was to help them
procreate and without that they are of
no use
as the number of fatherless pregnancies
went up the number of sexual pregnancies
went down rapidly science finally came
up with a reasoning for the asexual
pregnancies that were so wildly debated
it turned out that women had evolved
into asexual beings with time meaning
that their eggs could create all the
genetic materials that are required for
childbirth the process of reproduction
is called parthenogenesis as time passed
babies reproduced sexually became rarer
when scientists looked into it they
found out that eggs in women's bodies
had stopped receiving sperm even if
sperm was injected into the egg it died
instantly making sexual reproduction
impossible in addition because of the
lack of y chromosomes every child that
was born as a result of parthenogenesis
was a woman now the male species was on
the verge of extinction in 1965 eleanor
hamilton became the first woman american
president in history all this took was
for all of the men to die
as time passed the power dynamic shifted
and more women started being seen in
powerful positions things started to
change when the government introduced
the worker replacement program according
to which every man who holds a powerful
position in any institution had to be
re-evaluated to see if they are actually
fitted for the job or they got it
because of their male privilege eleanor
called it the weeding out technique now
if they can weed out nepotism and
psychopaths the entire workforce will be
gone because of the law hundreds of men
started to lose their jobs and go
homeless the agitated men all moved to
the woods in the countryside waiting for
women to realize their mistakes but by
the mid-1970s it was clear that women do
not actually need men to survive in any
aspect of their lives some men began to
return to society and take mediocre jobs
while others stayed on their ground and
started protesting the leader of men
darius smith claimed that their
organization wants respect and position
back because women have done enough
injustice by 1975 women represented over
three quarters of the population of
earth because of this all women's
menstrual cycles began to synchronize
and a new phenomenon called menstrual
synchronization was discovered i thought
this was a thing already
soon the world was united into one and
governed by an international
organization called the world's council
the government overthrew several
military projects because they weren't
needed anymore after world peace was
established they also stopped funding
nasa and focused on building a cleaner
and safer environment on earth by
developing electric cars to provide men
with proper accommodation the government
created sanctuaries all around the world
and asked all the male population to
move there men were provided proper
nutritious food shelters and
entertainment in the sanctuaries and
were asked to confine themselves in
those particular areas at first the men
protested the idea but didn't do much
when the sanctuaries were established
and they started living a quality life
at present darius smith still claims
that the men are only planning their
attack in the sanctuaries and have not
accepted the idea at all when technology
develops people start to research the
cause of asexual reproduction being
possible while science declares it as
evolution some people believe that a
comet passed the earth closely in 1952
and nine months later the first asexual
baby was born which means that the comet
had something to do with the
transformation finally it's been
confirmed that women are aliens however
the theory is claimed to be only a rumor
currently 37 year old andrew is the
youngest man on earth he works as house
help for a family that consists of only
women the couple iris balashev and tara
ganger have appointed him to help them
take care of their daughters andrew says
that he doesn't feel special for being
the youngest man alive because it has
always been like that for him his boss
iris says that andrew is a delightful
housemaid and is very good at his job
she likes him mostly because he is way
cheaper than a female housemaid she also
believes that his influence will be good
on her children and grandchildren
because they will be able to live as the
last few women who have male influence
in their lives andrew's other boss tara
isn't very fond of him because he has a
penis and because of his closeness to
iris iris paints andrew a lot which she
claims is for artistic purposes but tara
doesn't get the point
when the children go to the field for
their football match they bring andrew
with them for help but he is only
allowed to stay on the sidelines while
waiting andrew meets two men who are of
course older than him they too are house
help for another family of girls their
chat is disrupted by a teenage girl who
reminds them that a gathering of more
than two men is illegal the guys quietly
follow her orders and separate one day
while tara and iris are in an interview
telling people what it is like living
with andrew iris says that she likes
andrew a lot as the conversation goes
further it is clear to tara that her
parenting partner is attracted to andrew
she asks the interviewer to cut the
cameras and storms off when iris is
alone with the interviewer in the
kitchen she admits that she and andrew
have fallen in love with each other she
rushes outside to see him and the two
get into a heated discussion but things
get more interesting when they kiss the
kids watch them from nearby in utter
shock because they have never seen
anything remotely sexual between a man
and a woman tara witnesses this and
sends the kids back into the house
meanwhile the leader of the men's
extremist group darius comes forward
with his claims that they are being fed
food mixed with estrogen so their sexual
urges would be suppressed the men from
the sanctuary go on a hunger strike but
it only lasts for a day and a half
darius pretends that they have decided
to keep eating the food so no one
forgets what the men are going through
in the sanctuaries after being found
having an affair with his employer
andrew's work permit is revoked and he
is sent to a sanctuary in vancouver oh
no not canada he lives there for a while
but his mind and heart are back at the
house he cannot get iris out of his head
even for a second the other men living
with him have given up because they do
not have any reason to want to go back
to society but andrew is always thinking
of a way to escape he somehow manages to
send iris a letter and calls her to meet
him outside the sanctuary then one night
he escapes and finally reunites with her
the two have nowhere to run and they
believe that their love is valid so they
hold a press conference instead when
they logically explain their case to the
people women start becoming more open to
the concept of helping men from becoming
extinct people protest demanding the
government figure out a way to help men
their efforts paid off when iris and
andrew are legally allowed to get
married with a lot of scientific
research iris is able to become pregnant
with andrew's child scientists disguised
the xy chromosomes in the sperm to make
it seem like xx and hence iris gets
pregnant the movie ends as andrew says
that he doesn't want the child to be a
girl and iris looks at him in
disappointment
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching